blue holes are normally found on reefs
yet this wouldn't be the first time a
Chasm has opened up close to Australia's
East Coast in September 2015 a giant
hole appears overnight at a campsite on
Inskip point
swallowing a 1 000 foot long section of
Coastline cars and Caravans
a fear made all the more real by a
recent scientific Expedition close to
the Great Barrier Reef
researchers have recently discovered an
area where part of the reef is actually
breaking away and is perched above a
deep underwater canyon the giant
disintegrating slab is one and a half
miles long
it's only a matter of time that this
will eventually tumble down and will
create a tsunami that could be
absolutely catastrophic